that's something that we should be
looking out for generic 3d graphics as a
as an additional piece to the you know
30 year old viewpoint view matrix type
type setup or am i confused you're
confused but I think we can you know the
entire game is confused I don't think
I'm totally confused Roger you're not
totally confused for Connecticut okay I
think it needs it just a longer
discussion that's all okay that's fine
all right okay let's keep going then
all right on to audio so let's take a
look at some of these pages so speech
recognizer is completely new for 12 oh
right yes and yesterday we couldn't
actually try it out but um let me just
go ahead and move this unfortunately due
to that neural network problem I don't
think it's gonna be you I don't think
you can try it again today
okay fine but let's at least look it I
mean I've seen it before but let's at
least look at documentation is that
consistent with the wording of text
recognize I have looked
by sight but obviously things are
somewhat different no it's work right
now this is similar what does that mean
for audio here structural level oh I see
yeah it's kind of random for this
probably right I mean I'm not even sure
that's a necessary option for this for
speech recognizer to text recognize
where the words can be splattered all
over the page it's relevant
well actually it is relevant and the
thing that's relevant to it is not this
at all it's you know if I say hello
there
this is business hello there you want to
separate those two out did Julisa I'm
saying she wants to work I don't know
you tell me I mean it's a certain
interval of time or something but but
that's because that's also going to be
the other the cases that you want to
segregate are different speakers or
periods of non-speech in my opinion
because if you think about it a lot of
applications they'll be like like
imagine I don't know let's say you're
transcribing air-traffic-control
right you want each separate message as
you know there's a bunch of of silence
or noise followed by you know turn left
of heading such-and-such or whatever and
you want to be able to break those out
does that make sense yes then I think
that's much more relevant than list of
words which i think is kind of
irrelevant yeah and I do think I think
it's a structural level I think it's
some kind of you know how you separate
the components of the output make sense
it
I'm trying to think we are not going to
have that in 12
I'm guessing and I'm wondering how we
should release speech recognizing 12
honestly in function without also
without the current level specification
sentence word or something yeah I think
we should rip that out I think it's
irrelevant
maybe we should rip rip out properties
as well then because interval only makes
sense for if you can do this thing with
positioning the text I mean this speech
let's see trimmed audio continue yeah
that again doesn't make sense okay so
we'll go one art form I think so
you know I think so as the experimental
thing and it's just I a that's kind of
what we did with text recognized as well
at the beginning I think we didn't have
experimental factor well whatever but
but it was a one art form yeah first
when we released it yes this business
here how uniform have we been in stating
that assume your screen is frozen for me
is that the same for others I can see it
it's it's overriding it there you go
I'm asking about this this thing here
yes that's systematically added to
functions that require assets okay
same for if that should be if we should
start decorating some of this
documentation with some you know not I'm
not thinking about baba ki you know
curved roads or Keynesian exclamation
marks but some kind of decoration for
paragraphs like that
Roger what do you think I think if they
can be decorated within and not sort of
because there's only so many icons you
can have at the top level no no no we
don't want it at the top level I'm
saying I'm suggesting that when you go
to let's imagine you go to like come
well let's go here to like text
recognize oh great alright let me go to
a version which is working here by the
way Roger are we gonna push to get the
probabilistic computation top level tile
let's get through to design reviews and
if I have bandwidth I'll just do it then
there okay you know why is this not
working what am I doing wrong here it
works in
prototype today if this is a him oh this
is another one oh for goodness sake this
is a released build so something has
corrupted my system um do you just do
the rest slash tech spec yeah I can just
sending something here sending a chat
yeah but this is a bug that needs to
affects me needs to be checked that it's
not affecting my mobile machines as
Laura's happens to be
could you please look at the chat
channel okay okay okay um all right
let's look at this so what I'm
suggesting is yeah I mean I don't know
how it would work visually by the way
those are too big we don't have any
project management people here do we
yeah so am I gonna then do this I guess
I have to do this I I'm still waiting on
spec from Brian and okay I think you
need to push a little harder there I
loved it that um okay so what I'm
suggesting is that you know we we put a
different icon here in those cases or
something am I making sense Roger
yeah maybe indent something here let's
make sure that's discussed we're
supposed to have a let me just send mail
[Music]
okay okay um all right let's keep going
here
so language in
supporting that at this time don't we
have a dish a whole bunch of other
language models for a speech recognizer
we have I think we have one or two we
just have English now I think we are
really good at Chinese right yeah I
think so at least that so I suggest that
we um you know we'll make some statement
languages supported include blah and
blah mm-hmm right we better make sure
that we that that's fully tested because
I always gone to English at this point
so right I understand and we're not
ready yet because they don't think all
those things are is the language model
in fact hooked up at this time it is
there's been for a while tim has been
trying to speed up that language model
as well hey by the way did did there was
a student at the summer school who did a
pretty good project on adding
punctuation using machine learning okay
so if nothing else we could use her
Network sure um and I think she was
going to put it in the neural net
repository great um that's a pretty nice
project and there's also another project
that was done there was determining
whether a sentence is a question mm-hmm
so but I don't see going into speech
record oh yeah let's do okay yeah um
okay let's keep going [ __ ] recognized
so is that a real thing at this point
yes this one is not
proprieties is the main build the main
pitch
that's really weird
that's oh I see waiver not it is the
time series object I see I see what
you're saying you return for 40 Hertz
over this period type things that
correct I set this back when you do
quantization and seed it see that speck
down there yeah you can specify if you
want me details for instance okay that's
nice but what about returning it as a
sound object I guess that's gonna be
separate function something like audio
sound or some why why as useful as this
if not more useful but you may as well
have just a speech signal and we don't
have a good way of representing it as a
sound object wait wait wait wait wait
unless you say we just if look this is
returning the main pitch right so for 40
Hertz I play middle a on a piano I'm
gonna get 440 Hertz I played middle a
followed by middle G or something right
but it's gonna be changing over time I
know that I know and if you whistle it
might not be it sort of at a certain
beats or anything like that you know I'm
aware but what you're saying is you are
trying to return for 40 turning into you
know well let's say C goes to a you know
256 going to 440 right at a certain time
point in the time series correct yeah
but the time series is going to hold the
value like a 256 or something no what do
you mean no it's I mean I mean if I play
the note yes then it will hold that
value in the time series right yes so it
will have samples into time series but
it will vary and it won't follow and I'm
confused let's see if there's an example
yeah
that's the pitch
but that didn't look like that's a list
line plot that's not even a date list
plot well I mean there's no dates I know
but but doesn't list line plot work on
time series yes and what scale does
again the one that's in the time series
that's I think in seconds here okay okay
fine three point five all right okay so
what this is saying is this is like with
a little beep there is that right yep
okay so what you're imagining okay
so there's a separate issue which is
converting this to the closest MIDI to
the closest you know essentially back to
sound sound object right so for instance
if you whistle you know a kind of a tune
or something you can have that your
whistle played on a piano or a trumpet
or something I know as you say you can
transfer the whistle what what are you
saying yes yeah what if you used to that
spec up there to get the sort of the
media notes then you can transfer it to
what do you mean by many notes I mean is
it going to give them any number or
what's it gonna give cuz we use this
modified MIDI number as you know no and
that's what it's I think it's saying up
there sound note pitch is the one so
note pitch yes sir is there one letter
sound no expense okay okay so that's
gonna give a bunch of integers whereas
this is giving a bunch of things in
Hertz is that correct yeah that's in
Hertz right it's not it's not trying to
give them you know it's giving them as a
quantity array so to speak right I'm not
sure if I think there are numbers I
think they should be a quantity array or
there could be time series with
quantities yeah that's fine however you
want to do that but but my point is it
should be in Hertz because all over all
of the audio functions operate in Hertz
it isn't Hertz but the only question is
does it bring the unit along with it and
if I am okay I think it should by
default you can always say quantity
magnitude if you want to get rid of the
unit but okay so my question is what is
the analog of image graphics it will be
like audio sound which is a little bit
of a weird name right yes which is the
approximating sound object to an audio
and what you're saying here is that if I
do the sound pitch thing what would be
my way of mapping and this is something
we should think about actually because
when we invented sound we didn't have
time series right so arguably sound
should be able to eat time series making
sense yes we really haven't really
thought about that but I think
application examples will show you some
of the things that you want to do now
I'm not sure how cleaned up they are but
let's go down there is one example that
does convert to sound think the last one
maybe but look at those as well that's a
mess the way that's being done that's
really a mess yeah we need a better way
to do that and I would suggest the way
to do that is to be able to feed sound
note oh wow that's really messy anytime
you use sequence it's bad I don't even
know why it doesn't just say sound load
applied to whatever why isn't it not
just saying sound as well right a list
of all that junk yeah okay but in case
it seems to me that sound note should be
able to take a time series see what I'm
saying we should look into that okay all
right fine okay taking notes right
shuddhi yes I'm counting on you yeah
and this is all recorded okay it's true
- yeah okay so what do you mean if a
pitch doesn't detect you like
you should say something like if if
there isn't a lot of energy in a single
frequency or something whatever if you
give it a little clear on what that
means Oh a single picture together in
time well a single dominant pitch
because it's a piano for example the
fundamental has lots of energy in it but
there is other stuff too the thing is
the signal can have anything but we
assume a monophonic signal and we just
detect the first fundamental frequency
um and you're right if there is none we
give a missing okay okay so we talked
about yesterday the word frequency range
is just not right I mean maybe that
could be min max frequency I mean you're
thinking of it as analogous to plot
range yes what the heck is that
partition granularity again way to way
to that's something that all of these
sound audio processing functions have
there's an existing thing yes instead of
having that as a bunch of arguments it's
it's an optional thing what does it mean
it's how you how you chunk how you chunk
to sound how you chunk it when you're
processing it typically the three
arguments the duration of each chunk
overlap of them and the smoothing
function
and so audio joined for example how does
that have one of these is it relevant to
audio join I mean if it's taking pieces
of sound or am i confused
no it's we don't have it in audio joint
but shouldn't we because are you
thinking about leaving some gaps or
overlapping audio when you're joining
them I guess not but do we have a
version of audio join that does allow
that in the way that sound note sound
and sound no to allow that we don't
perhaps we should I'm wrong sorry so
there is an audio one T one audio 2 T 2
which specifies the start time and what
in audio join yes ok so then why don't
we have this option in audio join this
is really a different thing yeah
there is no partitioning happening in
audio joint to have partition
granularity alright ok whatever let me
know let me know chase that one
I don't know what you should call this
what do you want to call this frequency
range is just way too general I'm fine
with what you suggested yesterday and
today both yesterday allowed frequency
range I think and today min max
frequency range what does it actually
mean it is the frequency at which you
are actually trying to find it mm-hmm
so sometimes it could be the parameter
for the algorithm that detects pitch but
sometimes it could be something like a
post-processing
I think allowed frequency range is fine
it's not the most profound but it's fine
okay as we move on you know if you
really wants to you could say frequency
value and have that be the magnitude and
frequency be the thing in Hertz well I
see okay for the spec frequency
magnitude and frequency be the baking
maybe yeah I mean frequency magnitude
will be just the number and frequency
would be 75 Hertz for example um okay
okay let's go on speech synthesized so
we've already had a version of speech
synthesized I was playing around with it
yes so the the idea here and it's that
this voice styles if you looked at what
kind of voice can we have here yeah
let's go to voice styles and you will
find we we had a dollar voice styles
before in 11 3 that was listening just
the names of available voices now we
replacing that with the function voice
tiles bracket bracket which is a lot
richer than that so what are you saying
I should look at voice style yes
voice tiles and you can see you might
not like the design Stephen but but the
direction you're gonna like so you see
there is age gender language those are
important yeah I understand that so now
I have to say I don't like the design
because I mean look look let me give
some analogies to things like this okay
we've got different musical instruments
that's a bizarre list of things that I
don't think we've ever we've never had a
dollar variable for it I was going to
put it in the data repository what that
list is it's even gonna be system
operating system dependent I'm aware but
but I mean the analogy to that okay so
let me give you an analogy which which I
think works okay right now is to all the
font families okay which is system
dependent and it's just like look you
know but it's useful and I don't
understand why dollar voice stars isn't
fine for that it wouldn't be I mean
because how would you know by name what
the heck it is how do you know for these
fonts by name what the heck it is yeah I
think it's not a good design I really
don't think it's a good design to you I
mean okay look the reason that it's not
a bad design is because we actually have
the following thing that's true so you
never use it actually well I actually do
use it I do use it for programmatic
purposes right so this is where we are
displaying you know those right in the
autocomplete
but I think it's important to be able to
to pick someone in the right language
and probably gender as well I agree with
that I agree with that but the question
is okay so you could say the same thing
about fonts I want to pick a sans-serif
bold font yeah wouldn't it be nice if we
had a design like that maybe maybe but
let's think about it I mean that's it
okay let's let's look at the different
cases where we have things like this
okay because we also have that for our
own style sheets my making sense in
other words you could argue that there
are these things which are selectable by
tags yeah right and but they're pretty
arbitrary and you can't really count on
I mean you might be able to burn in okay
for any of these things all right so
what we do with fonts in the style
sheets is we have these font what are
they called font substitutions right yes
Oh [ __ ] psycho this is really broken
it's really needs to be fixed okay this
is this is that in twelve oh right
that's broken
[Music]
okay because that's also what you'd want
list of substitutions to try for font
family names so instead of Bob
you should try John I think what's that
no the point here is that if you see
Geneva use Helvetica okay and that's
gonna come up again if you have the Alex
voice or something right but I don't
think voices are as recognizable as
fonts you know Helvetica and Geneva or
very old standard
things I know but I mean like like you
know a rowboat Oh slab I actually know
what that one is like yeah but Oh Sarah
BEC I've no idea what that one is
right but so okay so the problem we're
trying to solve here is I think I think
what we're trying to solve is to give
the user a fighting chance without
experimentation to to get the right
choice what you want yeah so let's talk
about okay in the font case many times I
have just said let me just get let me
sample all of these and you can if you
want to with voices - yes but it's a lot
more bizarre because obviously here if I
want to sample all of them you know if I
just say you know and you might have
installed something like Chinese fonts
or no I understand I understand
you know that's fine that's easy enough
to do
and I can label them and so on right but
if I did that with audio if I did that
with speech synthesizer I would get a
goofy result right I mean I could can I
try it you know so how do I get so what
I get for voice is is dollar voice
styles right okay so it's a more modest
number I don't know whether it's gonna
stay modest or whether this is going to
inflate like fonts I would guess it will
follow the pattern of fonts which is
that it will gradually inflate but not
infinitely do you agree yeah that's what
I would mean I I expect that there will
be more and more elaborate would you
call them models for for generating sure
you know what are they called but I
think the other thing is you know unlike
with okay so what hasn't happened with
fonts is something which says you know I
want it in you know Thomas Jefferson's
handwriting right but arguably okay so
that is amusing just um
can you hear those things you need to
share your audio and I'm gonna do that
set up in your zone can zone panel you
need to add new share this sounds scary
in the audio options I don't see where
it is now because I'm seeing a
difference open well anyway all right
look I can hear these things anyway so
that's just freaking weird you might
want to take yourself off there um
that's in Chinese the last one of these
is in Chinese I hate but it's in Chinese
it's saying hello but it's trying that's
a funny one alright I have to get the I
have to share these because is it too
good to not sure um how do I do that now
do you see some button that says new
share I do guess if you click on that
then you re select your screen and then
say share audio oh sure
computer sound I see it yes okay so now
hello hello is what tag is that one I
mean but it's not saying it in so okay
what is this Alan W black hell no wonder
where Elvis is from well how do we find
that out
well with the new voice mails bracket
bracket okay I'm guessing this one is
your relevant three okay so you have to
go back to 12
okay so you're saying if I say voice
styles Alice it's not it's not not
turning black hmm
the prototype build yes
on the livestream are we going to
improve cloud support for audio the
answer is yes it's being worked on is
that a correct answer so far as you guys
know yes yes in fact the primary
problems have to do with the decoration
of audio not the and I think the
streaming of audio is is expected to
work well is that a correct statement
it's gonna use the same mechanism as we
are streaming sound object which has
been resolved already so the cloud can
stream a sound object yes Wisconsin a
man audio object right um okay so you're
saying voice styles okay of Alice
oh so if you say hello as an Italian you
just said that I did you can do that
well the UM okay okay
music alright I do agree okay so I'm
gonna make a different suggestion hmm I
mean what happens in the autocomplete if
what happened in the autocomplete here
was similar to what happens in the
font-family autocomplete which is to
show an indication of what you're going
to get we could imagine doing the same
thing in this autocomplete in The Voice
style autocomplete something like Alice
female Italian 35 but that would be
great if I think you we need to talk to
them because it's gonna be a little bit
more dynamic it's gonna have to adapt
for plan but so does it on the
font-family thing I guess it does yeah
right and that's completely pull yeah
okay but I mean honestly it's a bit of a
I kind of like having this voice styles
thing that you can I mean look being
able to understand the properties of the
thing and somehow being able to get this
association out it does seem useful
mm-hmm look the real way this should be
handled is these voices should be
entities and then they can have
properties up the wazoo you go what I'm
saying but I don't know what
can do that but then if you make that up
let's say you make it an entity
yeah can you really do that what is it
no yeah you can make it an entity it's
just a voice style entity I mean just
like we have for example what do we have
as entities
I mean figures that who I don't know
global these names are I mean can
someone can you have to Victoria's I
assume yes well if you can have to
Victoria's then we have a whole
mechanism for canonicalizing entities if
we want to have this discussion we
should get along choice in here for
imagine um um okay okay brother a Roger
you suddenly sound very loud to meet is
that that happens everybody else as well
really I know you know it's okay I
thought it might have changed with
sharing the computer audio okay but so
you know I think that will be the
correct solution and honestly that would
be a correct solution probably for fonts
as well because that way I mean right
now we don't have any way to ask for
properties of fonts right
actually we should know something about
fonts yeah right are they sans-serif are
they or whatever I mean what we do have
now so let me give you an example of
something similar to that is you know
character lambda for example let's try
that okay so that is a Unicode character
and it has just a whole boatload of
properties okay and that thing there
well it's not as big a boat as I thought
it was um but you see what I'm saying
this this properties um this is
different from and and I don't know how
to handle this this is a different thing
from the actual escaped land or escaped
which is just a string well actually
just a just a um you know a piece of
input yeah okay so that's an analogous
case where we have but here we have
naked strings representing the voices
and representing the fonts let's wait
for him to join events discuss this some
more but I'm still supporting the dollar
voice styles although I'm not certain
that it should return naked strings okay
and I completely agree that the
autocomplete should contain you know if
if your goal is to select a voice okay
so that there's multiple different as
suits are here um one is substitutions
you know if Alex is out to lunch do you
take Fred instead if you understand what
I mean right which is what we have for
fonts although I don't know how well
work through the font substitutions
table is um arguable
have the same issue for musical
instruments although we don't have that
because we're supporting a standard set
of MIDI musical instruments basically
did we ever have do we have a list of
musical instruments now did that get
generated
I just think could we just generate that
um I think I won just joined us here hey
Ellen okay I mean here's not an audio
yet here's now oh I okay um we are
looking at voices in speech synthesized
and we're observing that both with fonts
and voices so with voices there's a
proposal to introduce a new voice styles
function which would return things like
this is an Italian age 35 blah blah blah
right so what I was saying is it would
be more natural if we're going to do
stuff like that to make voices be
entities and then the issue is they are
quite system dependent and they're a bit
like fonts why are fonts not entities
but one question another question is our
musical instruments going to be entities
I mean I think they are entities some
way are yeah we though there is no audio
information associated with them
so this is a musical instrument but does
it work if I say sound
no no that's bad that should be made to
work is it just gonna fail here yeah
okay so that's a glitch that should be
made to work because right now I mean
okay so that shoddy one thing for you I
think there should be a dollar musical
instruments or dalam musical instruments
styles or something that's the ones that
sounded like it accepts you're thinking
what certain is do you want the list of
instruments that sound note accepts yes
yes okay but but the question is okay
the other glitch is that sound note
should accept entities as for
instruments as well as the strings
mm-hmm um Melissa we can add a property
with whatever whatever you need to know
to identify that for sound note and
exactly any sound note couldn't yep can
do it right um okay
Ethan black 86 on our live stream is
making the comment that the autocomplete
for fonts is great but difficult to
browse through having a built in style
browser GUI for any style family eg
sounds fonts graph layout set cetera
would be lovely I don't entirely
disagree I mean you know we've ended up
let's do an analogy we've ended up with
the somewhat bizarre color schemes
palette which is again an example of
pretty much the same type of thing yeah
and we have the same for for charts
should be under your dock you tools Oh
underneath I see right so the basic
point is there are a bunch of styles
choosing things and we don't have a
uniform way to handle one not
necessarily style as well I was thinking
event device choosing is similar to that
audio devices which want to pick from
four input devices recording or which
one to send to yeah I mean the problem
is okay so look building these things
maybe you know we have we have the
technology so to speak to build these
things what we don't have is a uniform
way to call them up
right because
I mean arguably the right way to do this
would be something like the following
that instead of having font-family you
know have a giant list there which and
it is going to be giant on most people's
computers there is a more modest list
together with something there's more
analogous to what we get for RGB color
which says choose color here right I
mean it would be nice to have the font
thing come up in that kind of way I
would think yeah okay so look we've got
some various user assistants things so
okay so let's let's parameterize the
different issues here
um I mean right now we have file browse
which does do did we have file browse do
we how do you don't need file completion
it will give you a similar separately
meant yes but we have a function that
brings up the browser mostly so there's
another system system dialog input yeah
there's another form of this though yeah
okay I mean there's a fine that's one of
these I wonder what the color one of
those does so oh well okay yeah even
black
suggesting style browser of colors or
sounds or whatever yeah that that was
kind of where I was about to go actually
is some it's not quite I mean it's a
whole collection of different kinds of
things and it's not necessarily styles
but it's something browse and then some
string name and that will be the
programmatic way to pull the thing up
they see the problem is what we really
need is something where we can either
browse it interactively or we can just
get a list of the possibilities assuming
it's a discreet list for colors it's not
a discreet list but for many of these
things like color schemes it is a
discreet list for chart elements I bet
it's also not is it what's the story
with chart elements schemes is that a
discreet list as well
no it's Primus or I set of things I mean
it's a discreet at some level but there
are the parameters right so each one of
these is more like a pure function than
it is like a a string name right what's
the deal on system all over these kinds
of things are there a boatload of other
ones there how to phrase it to look like
this problem well you've got that
browser you've got the gallery thing
Valerie yes are you talking about system
model or are you talking about Wolfram
language I'm talking about Wolfram
language with system modeler and in it
too so to speak okay okay but Senate so
Roger that that gallery thing the plan
is to rename that right what is the plan
to name that I think that we will
eventually transition over to a resource
system back our example is going to be
resource system back and then we'll
figure out what to do there because we
got to give users a fighting chance to
get something to play so to speak so we
can't let it go until we have the
replacement no I understand okay so let
me also comment then but the resource
system is another backing for example
for the voices we could imagine I have
no idea how these voices work right now
but I wouldn't be surprised if there was
an OS package that you could you know if
basically some new voice little clumsier
you know it's it's this needs to be kind
of real-time right well not the first
time you use it I mean in other words if
you're gonna load in and I don't know
whether this is happening you know the
the whatever you know the James Earl
Jones voice or whatever it is right
hmm um no it's it's kind of true yeah it
it could be various extensions and all
that um no no duck right
yeah even black on our livestream is
commenting that it would be nice to bill
to browse all the string options and sub
options to any symbol yeah that's a
complicated problem because
unfortunately those things are richer
than just a straight list of symbols in
many cases yeah I'm not but I want to
come back to this problem because what
we mean this is in a way like a gallery
um yeah programmatic access to the to
the options is closer to being a reality
with Wolfram language data um but I mean
you've got now the system model what is
it called system model examples I'm not
keen on this as such but but just to
give a sense of this this is another
case okay and question for Alan
are there any right now the entity
documentation pages are providing yet
another case of basically essentially
listing off entities is that true I mean
only a subset of them I think in most
cases you there there's nothing on those
that lists a ton of entities there's
there's a small set of sample entities
and entity classes for for every exposed
type that are also programmatically
accessible okay
but it's only it's like vibrant and in
each case okay but the problem here is
you know what we want to do all right so
look some of these are discrete some of
them are not discrete some of them are
you know many of them are quite fluid as
in they come from the operating system
or they're things where one could easily
see a new version having a bunch of
different ones and so on right so the
problems are you know what are the
problems we're trying to solve one
problem is I got am I doing here
why go to somehow
give information that makes it easy to
choose
yes I understand but that's not the only
problem we're trying to solve I mean one
thing is you know how to choose okay
another thing is expose a programmatic
list of everything list maybe with
filtering right for the case where
you're basically programmatically um
okay how to choose one interactively
let's see what's another case another
case is gosh what am I missing here oh
sorry I was just realizing there were
other cases here what did I miss here
well I mean okay how to choose one
interactively breaks into autocompletes
and palettes and I suppose within
autocompletes we have either a menu
listing or a chooser right right and the
palette could be just a bigger version
of the chooser but it's a different
place form factor wise okay the next
question is I mean a question here is
all the things were okay yes here's
another one find the properties of a
thing of one of the choices so one of
the things we did for the plot themes
was to build a kind of a iconic
prototype so that doesn't tell you
everything about it but it tells you
enough to hope well that's what you're
doing here as well yes
right so I mean a typical strategy here
iconic prototypes I'm thinking for the
iconic prototypes the voices we ensnared
with political political correctness or
something I don't know what it's like do
you have the Italian you know wearing
the Venetian gondola you know whatever
some other characteristic Italian dress
I mean honestly that would allow people
to pick quickly to do that
yeah do we really want to go there I
don't know it's a good exercise for the
design department for your list is to
peak programmatically
for instance we language identify the
text is Italian maybe even be gender
identify the text is spoken by a female
how're we gonna do that if it's Mel I
don't know down the road we may have
some gender identification on text
shortly that's that's one of those
talking about shoes are football but
anyways I think general idea peak based
on context what did you see
sure but that's an automatic pic right I
agree with you there's no point in
having a I mean it's gonna be hopeless
to have a British voice speak Chinese
mm-hmm okay so then then you're pointing
out automatic picking based on context
of some kind AG voice suitable for
Chinese okay but let's come back to the
I by the way I don't think my idea of
these illustrations is totally insane
for the voices well maybe it is insane
because these voices will come and go
well no if we can generate okay question
the thing you're generating that's that
Association that says that you know
whatever it is URI here is I mean
essentially what's happening is this
name like URI I can guess that URI is
intended to be Russian right might be
wrong but I can guess that and that's
sort of the idea here and the surprise
here was that Alice seemed to be Italian
whatever yeah that's just weird because
you know that seems like oh well maybe
what's that one hello I'm very confused
although what's that that was Alva but
but why is Alice Italian it's someone
someone decided on that we didn't pick
their names no I understand but it's a
stupid name for that because it's not
what you would expect I mean you know
what you should do I mean we have a
great way to pick this stuff right if we
pick for example let's just pick you
know in the case of Alice for instance
look at this look at how wonderfully we
can pick this yeah I understand if you
million names for WolframAlpha yeah yeah
I mean look at this we will be able to
predict from here you know the most
common age of an alice is 63 years so
that's a good way to pick but whoever
picked this one it's it's kind of dopey
I don't I think it's I don't think it's
a common Italian name I've never known
anybody Italian called Alice but
whatever um what do we think this one
like comet
is comet-like a misspelling of Kermit
the the Irish name oh I have no idea
there you go
so you you couldn't guess I can't guess
from these names but I think that badly
you know honestly I think it just badly
don't I mean okay so I'm gonna guess
that one is Hindi or something or some
other Indian language but I might be
completely wrong but I mean so up until
now we didn't have this meta information
even so that's that took some to do for
us I understand well where do we get the
meta information from it is it correct
is coming yeah it's coming from the
operating systems or for the few that
that are from other generic voices for
all platforms which ones are generic
voices Allen black SLT which sounded all
for by the way
Allen black what is uh what is our
default voice is it is it like Alex for
the for the Mac I think alex is that a
general default voice it is definitely
the system synthesizer on Mac and
Windows and I think we try to look into
what's the system settings as you can
save what's your preferred language
what does SLT stand for
whose name initials is that for for
those that we could figure it out we
spelled it out as Alan black and so Alan
black is some voice actor or something
who happened to make that recording is
that right I actually think it's this
sign it's the researcher okay fine yes
seems to be that gentleman yep and uh
you know I ran into the the woman who
did the Siri voice at CES had a quite
strange conversation in the end um I
think was captured by some some tech
magazine video thingy okay
in any case okay so what are we going to
do here so first point is okay so let's
look at
the different cases okay so what are the
examples of this so we have fonts we
have musical instruments we have voices
we have color color schemes what else do
we have devices one that was another one
possibly devices
via audio devices for example
let's see by the way I'm gonna save this
away and what on earth is this this is
I'm gonna save it in style pickers one
okay um okay anyway so we've got these
various examples of things that we need
to pick and iconic prototypes I mean in
some cases they're cheap like fonts it's
trivial to generate it in the case of
voices it's not so cheap although I know
do we want to see we're kind of way over
time could somebody see if Jeremy is
around
I think he's expecting me in another
meeting and just oh no no maybe not can
somebody see if Jeremy's around I'll see
if I can find him Thanks
um
you
okay
Allen I mean Allen do you have any
thoughts here relates that for instance
for speech synthesized I don't know if
this is gonna be feasible but if you
could recognize what language the string
is in you could sure use a good job with
that
yeah I mean you know we've got language
identifying it works well it's it fast
it's better be fast it's fast yeah it's
a fairly small feed-forward network I
believe once the I I believe that's fast
and I believe that we've also used that
for example we have a similar thing when
you type equals no you start typing into
a string see that it's offering to
convert to a text cell and that's the
language identifier I mean that that
particular one is just a classifier for
yeah you know text versus code basically
okay but this particular issue find the
properties of a choice you know for
example if I go here and you know pastel
for example you know one thing I want
and why do I want to find the properties
of a choice eg for use in filtering
right in filtering a and exposure list
because I might want to find all of the
I mean here I might want to find I don't
know all of these that have I mean for
instance for the color lists okay you're
supposed to those continuous ones to
design new ones because someone had
decided to sort to color list so there
was nearby colors next to each other but
in a pie you got to be able to pick out
the next slice from the neighboring one
so they need to be contrasting they
can't be near but but that's we had
particular so what are you saying that I
mean this is a we assigned a bunch of
new ones because there were none that
that were we have a indexed color
choices is that correct yeah so round 45
or so there's a bunch of new ones that
we added
okay but now you know these things here
could again by the way I assume that
these come up in the autocomplete if
your if your auto completing like for a
pie chart what the color scheme is don't
think that I'm not sure well they
probably should I don't think you could
tell when you tell tell what that it's
an electron if you pick one of the first
ones you're gonna have a really bad pie
charts if you pick all the ones that
were designed originally you're gonna
have a really bad pie chart no I
understand that but that means that for
the pie chart we should you know we
should be selecting down for the
autocomplete to show only color schemes
that are halfway reasonable for the pie
chart right hey Jeremy did you join us
we are looking at things like fonts
color schemes other things that need
chooses of various kinds and one of the
cases that we're running into is voices
where obviously we're you know the first
guess would be that the names were
determinate and there's an attempt at
that but it turns out Alice is an
Italian okay okay and so that I had
raised the possibly crazy idea of iconic
little personality icons for these it's
probably completely crazy well why is it
crazy you know if we this one says
Indonesian there's an Indonesian flag
yeah countries are fine anything beyond
that I think is getting into you know
dangerous territory well but listen what
we have here is let me show you
something right so so here it turns out
I mean a little blob with a piece of
sample text that talks that'd be great
if I could hear it and you know but you
can't hear but look at this case Jeremy
that's ten voices and you can't tell
squat even if I open one of these
well I say I won't even see anything
here you have to hear it no no I know I
understand I mean if you can you can
hear it you know like like hello
couldn't we have an inch below Alice be
an entity that has a little player
instead of a string I guess it's the
string now well right that's why so
Allen assumed we were talking about that
here's what I would favor okay
I mean unfortunately some languages
don't have flags conveniently like
English for example but what do people
do that I used they typically use a
combined you know the accents pretty
pretty high on to the flag yeah
absolutely right you're absolutely right
so let's take a look here at what well
let's look at what all of these are okay
do we still have to all avoid styles
here right just copy them over um let's
just take a look at what all of them are
you could ask for voice styles all to
get all oh really
okay here we go
actually you know I can iconographically
okay so there clearly are reasonable
icons here
first of all most of the ages of the
same looks like or close enough to the
same it doesn't matter
the thoughts on the live stream is
pointing out back in the days of old my
GPS used flags yeah I remember I you
know I picked this Australian woman
voice on my Garmin GPS I thought I was
being very exotic and I turned out that
was the that was the all-time favorite
voice to pick and that particular woman
started to launch a singing career based
on her appearance in on the on the
Garmin GPS I think I had was what
amounted to a pissed off British woman
on my GPS in Europe fair enough well
folks commenting that Homer Simpson Adam
was a flag of him and John Cleese had a
was um was the Python foot oh I see I
see I see
the foot from Monty Python as opposed to
the foot of a Python which it's a snake
it doesn't have feet never mind okay but
look clearly here these could be flags
now but we've but here we've got two
female oh no we've got traditional
Chinese and simplified Chinese so are
there repeats here yes so there are
multiple
voices of that are a similar age okay
well first of all we can and I was being
stupid and thinking about the the you
know national dress obviously irrelevant
flags or what we use um although I don't
know with Portuguese but probably that
is but that is either Brazilian or you
know Portugal Portuguese it's okay so
flags were clearly workable the question
is then how do we actually expose well
okay so the first thing we're trying to
do is to get an autocomplete to work and
for that flags would work well I think
now you're claiming that there are some
repeats here like here Jorge and Juan
are repeats for Spanish
[Music]
okay and Alan W black and Alex are
repeats for English so how would we
handle those probably we could handle
those just by giving their names I think
so yes
because you know you're already getting
a lot of the useful information from the
flags but but that's how we handle the
autocomplete we still haven't handled
the other features of our um yeah I mean
the problem Jeremy for you is we've got
these different cases we've got the
pallets we've got the autocomplete menus
we've got the choosers like the RGB
color chooser and so on right it's a
bunch of inconsistent things and we need
to standardize them and we're really way
over time here you see here I think I
think we have to wrap this meeting and
whatever that was so we're gonna have to
pick this up and we're gonna need
another for the original image and audio
well we're making good progress but
we're not through this yet right it's a
real problems I mean I'm glad we were
spending time on it actually it's good
yeah so let's let's branch off a
separate meeting um if I can let's
a separate meeting about these choosers
and so on what have we call them Pickers
choosers whatever okay and let's let's
maybe if in when we do that we can get a
project manager involved and actually
get some maybe it should be parth
because it's gonna feed into user
assistance and then let's get samples of
all of all of the visuals that we have
for all these things and let's see what
we can do with it in the meantime I
really prefer you know I have to say I
prefer dollar voice styles to this voice
styles selector thing I mean I
understand I don't know whether there's
any hack that we can do to take the
string names and be able to essentially
do entity property queries on the string
names I'll learn any ideas for anything
like that from external eff question
sorry the question is we've got naked
string names for these voices but we
have this new proposed function which
you don't think is making it voice
styles that will give us some properties
of those things the question is do we
have a an analogy of something where
there's a naked string and we ask her
properties of it hmm
not only within the like specific domain
data functions I can't think of that I
suit you say so something like a country
data would ask for that you could yeah I
mean it does a country data of quotes
it's a way will work even if it's layers
in the identity but we don't have an
ally mean this would be a voice style
data function but that would be a hack
right but
if you want to just keep the
functionality there shoddy
why don't you make this a voice style
data function okay okay and just I mean
for now we just put it as experimental
but it's not gonna make it but we just
so that we can experiment with these
things and we can find the data I guess
as long as we don't go back to dollar
voice tiles which doesn't or maybe we
will if we want dollar voice stars we
want dollar voice tiles so that you know
we have voice style theta okay okay we
will need to figure out how to do that
okay okay all right
for those who are on our live stream we
are about to switch to another live
stream for another exciting meeting
about language design and so we'll see
also and and we'll see the people from
this meeting in a follow-up yep later
okay bye bye